nobody saw those movies right because
nobody says honey let's look through the
tv guide thingy and see if there's any
wonderful things about racism or any
things about diversity i i really yeah
you know what i like at the end of the
day there's a really great
diversity humor
right there isn't any
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an american playwright a filmmaker whose
works include glenn gary glenn ross the
verdict wag the dog and more and author
of the new book recessional the death of
free speech and the cost of a free lunch
i've got a copy in my hand right now
david mamet welcome to the reuben report
thanks so much glad to be here i've
wanted to talk to you for quite some
time and i was going through the book
this morning and i thought man
this guy sees the world sort of as i see
the world so why don't we do a little
101 first for for people that aren't
that familiar with you
um what got you into
playwriting writing screenplays
did you always have something to say and
wanted to put the pen to paper
well yeah i was raised as a smart ass
and everyone always said when i was a
kid nobody likes a smart ass but i
didn't find that to be true
because uh
i always made jokes and i always
dramatized my mother used to say
david why must you dramatize everything
but because that's what i you know i was
born with that gene just like you know
sandy kovacs was born to throw the
fastball and because that worked i never
did anything else you know i would never
do any school work and i worked at a
million menial jobs we'd call them entry
level jobs now we call them menial jobs
then but when i realized there was this
thing called the theater
and that i could actually get in there
and um have the most fun in the world i
was never coming out and that's the
thing that i see about young people
whatever they're going into if they
discover something for example aviation
they discover the theater they discover
the military if if
if it's in their dna
they say you can kill me
but you're gonna have to kill me because
i'm never leaving so that's how i was
about above the theater so i started
writing plays when i was very young and
got from there into writing and
directing movies and
and the rest is uh you know there it is
yeah so i do want to jump into the
movies a little bit uh but let's start
with the book because uh your defense of
free speech but really beyond free
speech your defense of america and your
explanation of sort of this very strange
pivotal moment that we're in where we're
either about to
continue or maybe reinvent it perhaps or
just let the whole thing go
i think is really
apropos it's what i'm thinking about a
lot it's what i'm talking about on my
show all the time um how when did you
really start realizing something was
wrong here
well i wrote a book about 20 years ago
called the secret knowledge
uh a political book and it was looking
at what happened in new york and was
happening in the theater was happening
i grew up as a red diaper baby right all
my dad was a labor lawyer and everybody
we knew
the more radical people were the
communists but in our in our thing they
were all first generation uh immigrants
they just wanted to make a living and
they were liberals and uh what liberal
meant then was give some money to the
naacp and the blasey
and put your kid in the episcopal
reformed uh a temple
and um and
they'd all fought in the second world
war so everybody loved america but
america to them meant to do your job
raise your kids
don't get in the other guy's way
exhibit liberal tolerance if you can and
try to
try to take care of yourself although at
that time and again now we jews were a
despised race when i was a kid
there was still restricted hotels didn't
accept jews
clubs that didn't they were very open
about it no no hebrews needed apply
professions that didn't accept jews and
so like as jews down for the last 2000
years we said well okay
i can figure this out i'll keep my head
down and i hope nobody kills me
and so this i was born right out two
years after they were throwing my people
our people into ovens so that's the
world that we grew up in that i grew up
in
and um
i just discovered first of all my jewish
identity and i said wait a second
i'm a jew right there's a great people
we don't have to keep our head down i
want to discover what it means to be a
jew so i started studying the torah
and i said okay there's two things one
there's yiddishkait right the idea of of
the eastern jewish the ashkenazi
heritage where all my people came from
you know which is broadway and upper
broadway in new york and cafilte fish
and speaking a little bit of yiddish and
blah blah blah very good but the nazis
the germans are destroyed there doesn't
exist anymore it still existed when i
was a kid because there were the
immigrant generation and their kids it
was my parents
and
they're gone now
and so that civilization is just the
magnificent thousand year long very rich
civilization of the eastern european
jews is gone
but the thing which is not god is the
torah and so i started studying the
torah and reading the torah and i said
oh my god this is a record
of human experience it's told in story
form but we just tell everything on a
story form right that's how we
communicate with each other right and i
i realized i said
they said that the uh german humor is
all based on the bathroom and french
humor is all based on the bedroom
but jewish humor is all based on the
mind it's based on ambig the
incredible
inbred
adoration of ambiguity
and um
the torah takes it down to the bare
bones
and it says wait a second here's
something you aren't going to understand
right why did god create the snake
why did god the first act that human
beings
perform
first off eve
turns your back on god and and then the
first act that adam performs the first
thing
that a human man says is he blames his
wife he rats her out he says the woman
made me do it so if you read through the
torah time and time again you say i just
don't get this
i want to make sense of this it's not
how to do this and you'll be a good
person it's things which are shocking
so when i grew up everybody was all of
all the jews were about buddhism and zen
buddhism and what the sound of one hand
is clapping and the zen cohens well okay
very good indeed but everything in the
torah
is a provocative koam it just doesn't
make sense until you have to look at it
and look at it and figure out what did
it mean and when you figure it out you
realize it's all about human nature
which means about my nature
that everything in the torah is about
betrayal and incest and adultery and
bastardy and murder
and that's who we are that were
incredibly flawed
so i took that
that study and that understanding of the
world and to try to apply it
to the world that i see around me say
wait a second how did we end up here
okay so the answer is not
the democrats took us here right which
they did or that the
marxists have come out of the woodwork
or that the
which they have or that the press
has um
has imploded upon itself
the answer is something different that
these things that occurred to me
are there not the cause but there were
the result so they're the result of what
they're the result of a certain point in
civilization and so if you look at the
torah
that point is it's perfectly clear to
the tower of babel these are the richest
people in the world what do they want to
do they wanted to raise a tower to
heaven so they can be like god and it
all came tumbling down around them so i
say okay i get it what's greenpeace
trying to do they're trying to raise
what's the aclu trying to do they're
trying to raise a tower to god so they
can be like god so they can be in charge
of the world so i started to see the
world in a very very different way as
and so i said what brought us to this
point well the same same thing that
brought the tower of babel it was
prosperity
that that i realized that the
billionaire's children
don't work
and when the boss
stops being the assistant and becomes
the boss
he forgets how to use the xerox machine
right and he doesn't uh put his gas in
his car
and he doesn't mow his own lawn and he's
not connected to anything around him so
what happens to this rich person
they become frightened they surround
themselves with security
and they know themselves to be a a
flawed human being but they forget they
say wait a second i'm like a god there's
nothing that i can't buy there's nothing
that i can do i'm the richest country in
the world i don't have to work
oh americans won't won't uh do stoop
labor
will open the borders right i don't have
to defend myself haha because we all
really want the same things so as soon
as you say it's geopolitically we all
really want the same things some other
guy over there is going to say these
guys are suckers i'm going to take
advantage of them that's the history of
the world that's what we see now
so
with all of that in mind i mean that's
very much what you're talking about in
the book so so do you think there is a
rebirth of people realizing some of this
related to
either the bible or age-old stories
versus sort of the purely secularism on
steroids that we we seem to be stuck in
at the moment well i don't think it's a
rebirth i think it's there all the time
half of the country anyway voted for
donald trump
these people and you know who it is it's
what happens when the people become too
prosperous is the country uh divides any
country into the rich and the powerful
and then the parasites
who live off of the rich the power won't
want to supplant them for example black
lives matter you know in the squad and
the poor who are getting bribed to stay
poor which is what we see in the inner
cities
[Music]
but the people who have always been
been america have been the middle class
right then the the doctor the lawyer the
butcher the baker the candlestick maker
the shoemaker because they have to deal
with each other they have to deal with
the supply system they have to deal with
customers they have to deal with credit
the rich don't have to deal with any of
those things and neither do the poor so
the middle class is very very connected
to each other but the middle class is
vanishing vanishing vanishing and
especially with with with the with a
with the centralization of distribution
and then with
outsizing outsourcing everything to
china
so but there's still a middle class and
it's basically in the south right
because the south as the last vestiges
of the wonderful heritage of agrarianism
right and
the farmers harry truman said the farmer
is the smartest guy in the world because
he's sitting on his
tractor 12 hours a day and he's thinking
about the weather and about the
railroads and about the credit and about
the price of grain and about
the farmer realizes that every moment he
spends on tax task a
he can't spend on task b
right which is
tomsol
right and which is hayek
and which is milton friedman it goes
back to you know jon stewart no
you only have so much energy if you
spend it on a you can't spend it on b
so i really also realized this that the
most all pilots are conservative right
because the pilots realize i just have
so much gas
you know i can spend that in a or i can
spend it on b but
i thought we could just print money make
up gas you can't exactly so you can't
spend it twice
so friedman says price just indicates
the way that we get together to say i'm
not going to ask you how hard you work
for the money and you're going to ask me
how hard i worked on the shoes what did
we enterprise we'll do business but if
everything becomes centralized we're no
longer doing business with each other
the the rich and the poor
are
both look for ways to gain power
so the black lives matter and antifa and
the squad and blah blah and the teachers
unions right in the service you can say
you know okay i know how to gain power
power comes through unity power comes
through strength well okay to a certain
extent yes there's something in the in
the
in the labor movement but on the other
hand that's fascism right is that nobody
has to take responsibility because
they're all part of the fascia they're
all part of the group
and the rich say yeah [ __ ] it i don't
care raise taxes i don't care
i'll uh you know i'll i'll stay here 180
days in the republic of santa monica and
then i'll go to a low tax state
so what happens
the rich having to spoiled
california oregon washington
uh new mexico go to a low tax state and
take the virus with them
they didn't cause it they're the they're
like a
forgive my being blunt they're like a
pimple
something's on right you don't get the
pimple because your skin is upset you
get the a pimple because your your your
metabolism is upset right your blood is
so
i realized that to say of you know biden
and kamala harris and all those guys
look what they've done
they're just opportunists
that's all that they are this is an
absolutely predictable point
in uh human history
and it's up to us to decide okay what
would we like to have happen and let's
see if we can bring it about yeah and
that really is what the book is about i
do want to say for the record as a uh
californian refugee who just moved here
to florida i came here for the right
reasons to do the right things so uh i
will keep this place as as free as
florida has always been uh you're in la
still you are in la still anyone that
listens to the last few minutes is going
wait a minute how is this guy in
hollywood in la
saying these things how can you make a
living still how can you get gigs can
you get can you walk into caa and
they're going to still talk to you i
mean how has that been for you
well as we used to say in chicago i
drove my car here i didn't come on the
bus
so uh
i've
continued to have a
pretty wonderful god-given career as a
playwright to do my plays all around the
world in fact i gotta play now on
broadway with lawrence fishburne and sam
rockwell and darren chris an older
player of mine called american buffalo
and as far as getting hired in the movie
business i
i'm too old to sit in a room with 12
guys named jason
[Laughter]
you know my agent they're all named
jason
but how but how about that i mean just
living in la right now i mean after two
years of of covid and just the way the
whole industry has collapsed i mean that
was one of the reasons there were many
reasons i left l.a but it was also that
there was it wasn't just the covid
crazies everything and the crime and the
homelessness okay we could do all that
it was just that it felt that there was
nothing cool about it anymore whatever
whatever was cool and creative about la
felt completely gone to me
well you know cities grow for a reason
and when the reason is gone they get
repurposed when i first first worked in
new york a million years ago i was
working in greenwich village and
anything south of houston street was a
slum absolute slum
there were people who were squatters who
were artists and homeless people living
in those um
lofts that used to be a manufacturing
district and eventually the city came in
and said okay okay you artists you can
live here forever we caught 200 bucks a
month you can rent so i got friends
whose grandchildren are living in lofts
for 200 bucks a month and so for 30
million dollars okay so now what used to
be lofts and manufacturing becomes
artists so as always
along with our brothers the homeless the
bohemians come in and repurpose a
neighborhood and because the bohemians
come in and repurpose a neighborhood
then the restaurants come then the shops
come so now soho becomes the prime
shopping district on the east coast and
people come from all over the world to
shop in solo gets repurposed right what
happens then
black lives matter and the rat the the
writers come in and say [ __ ] you
they clean everything out
what does the new york police do about
it
nothing
so what you see is what started off as
an industry catering to the shipping
trade in new york then became abandoned
and then became squatter a place for
squatters both the homeless of the
artists and then became a shopping
district and is now
uh going
yet again going to become a slum
so this is the history of the world so
how do you liken that to l.a what do you
think is going to happen to l.a and i do
have to tell you that every time i
mention california on my show
gratuitously i have to put five dollars
into this jar and at the end of the year
i'm giving a couple thousand bucks away
to someone who lives in california to
move to florida so if you're looking to
move
i might have a couple couple thousand
for you
what do you think is going to happen to
la
well first i want to say about miami is
i used to go to miami all the time in
the 50s with my dad who had business
down there we fly down there and i'm
still trying to get the zinc oxide out
off my door
yeah it's quite sunny but it's all right
what's going to happen to let's happen
to la here's the thing
just as there's no
there's no business like no business
there's no when you do away with the
theaters and you do away with the the
possibility of um
independent production
and
there's no reason for the film industry
anymore
to be in l.a
i mean if they came out here because
there was there was a sunshine and they
made a bunch of crap every year they
made a bunch of crap on a couple of
movies that were memorable and a couple
of people
snuck through and made something
beautiful and a couple of people snuck
through and made a fortune and sometimes
the two people were the same and
sometimes that they weren't but
so that
the industry grew up here first because
it was sunny and second because they uh
they were fleeing the edison company
which held the patents in new york so
the bootleggers came out here to make
movies so the studios just like soho
grew up around these bootleggers right
and then they gave rise to this
incredibly magnificent community had 5
000 people working as as musicians and
sent their kids to graduate school here
right 10 000 people working as actors
all of the professions and so forth were
a middle class that supported the film
industry
but as films became more more and more
successful they became more and more
expensive
and so any film that you see
when i first started making movies my
producer guy who taught me about movie
making said any movie can be made for
any price you can make the hundred
million movie dollar movie
for five million dollars back today with
an iphone you can make it for 50 grand
and you can make the 50 grand movie for
100 so people are making comedies which
is two people standing in a stupid room
talking to each other for 200 million
dollars to make any sense so what
happens because they have so much energy
and so much money to distribute what
happens is it attracts parasites
they suggest like if you're rich you say
well i i have a housekeeper how about
that oh i'm more richer i have two
housekeepers whoops got to keep an eye
on them i'm going to have a household
manager oops got to keep an eye on them
because they have friends under the
delivery i'm going to get security
whoops now i'm going to get us so
eventually
the superstructure brings down the ship
right there's more super there's more
there's more restaurant critics than
cooks or um customers so there's no
reason for the business to be here
anymore in fact most of it isn't but yet
we have these huge like you mentioned
caa
uh
people who if they all went away nothing
would change in the movie business
but they they spawned
other
parasites right
the agent gets a sub agent and the sub
agent gets a blah blah blah and then
people get a manager to deal with the
agent no one's ever exposed with a
mammogram told me what manager does
so there's all of this superstructure
but there's
but who's working
i am proud to say that i've never had a
manager i have agents i'm still not
totally sure what they all do but i
never had a manager because that one was
well beyond me
yeah now the the job of the agent is you
give him 10 to say jesus i tried
everybody i did the best i could
yeah i get him the deal he takes 10
percent and uh i signed something it's
pretty good pretty pretty good gig
but so do you think so so what are you
doing there still i mean if you if you
feel this about l.a i asked this to all
of my la friends which is why i'm asking
you i mean most have left already but do
you what's going to come of this place
well it's
dead i mean for example i started
looking in new york
many years ago 40 years ago they started
putting up the
the uh i saw it first in chicago they
started putting up the nicknames of the
streets on the street signs
i grew up in chicago state street state
street all of a sudden it's state street
that great street
go to new york broadway broadway
broadway the great white way well when
they start putting up the nicknames on
the street son what you're saying is
guess what used to be here
right something that it ain't
something that's not there anymore so in
martha's vineyard and cape cod
and nantucket when i was a kid i had
friends in the east who were
their parents were professionals they
were doctors lawyers indian chiefs blah
blah blah and they had a place that they
rented on those
outliers right and they started i
started making a little bit money in my
20s and my friends said why don't you
buy a place over there you know on the
ocean there's nothing between you and
portugal it's going for nothing so i say
yeah no yeah no yeah no so now those
places are selling for 50 and 100
million dollars
but you're not gonna find
anybody who makes harpoons
on martha's vineyard which used to be a
whaling port
it's gone right so that
that soho and and chelsea used to live
was where the ship's chandlers live when
new york was originally one of the great
seaports of the world
right and when i was a kid working there
it was the it was the capital of the
world but but you can't be the cultural
capital of the world without artists
right and the reason that the cities
existed
was
you took disparate elements which would
never ever meet in life for example uh
in chicago's woman who wrote a book
about 20 years ago called terrible
honesty about harlem in the 20s she said
you have these three groups that are
completely scorned and they have their
own wonderful cultures black america gay
america and jewish america right but
they all met in harlem and they met on
broadway and they cross-pollinated each
other's incredible energy but now we're
completely separate in the city i mean i
say i go into my neighborhood
restaurant and
of santa monica i said that the
definition of diversity is someone who
has 10.1 percent body fat
yeah i mean they destroyed santa monica
the promenade the whole thing they
destroyed it
yeah no it's uh you know the you know
the diversity of somebody who hasn't had
botox
so there's no cross-pollination
cross-pollination anymore and what
happened to free speech
is the democrats and republicans don't
even speak to each other anymore
those who used to meet at the synagogue
at the church
right at their kids baseball game
uh i got a friend
she's a she's a black woman and a white
guy across the street rather than a
baseball game and she was talking to her
kids or black kids about something
rather and he said excuse me you
shouldn't the white guy says well excuse
me you shouldn't talk to your kids that
way about racism
that's it she said she's saying to their
kids racist there he said racism is all
gone get out there and play big deal
that's white woke 101 right there
so so what do you think hollywood
can produce i mean do you see anything
sort of new and inspirational coming out
of that machine we're shooting we're
taping this right now just a couple days
after the oscars which i realized that i
didn't even know the oscars were on of
course i found out because of the slap
heard round the world but then when i
went through the best movie list and i
went through a bunch of the other lists
i did it live on the show i think i had
seen one of the films you know i flipped
through netflix and hulu and it's very
hard to find something that feels new or
original or or inspirational that the
machinery because of the reasons you're
talking about the hollywood machinery
seems unable to give us or maybe can
occasionally choke out something new and
fresh but there just doesn't seem to be
anything left
well there isn't i mean nobody saw those
movies right because nobody says honey
let's look through the tv guide thingy
and see if there's any wonderful things
about racism or anything about diversity
i i really yeah you know what i like at
the end of the day there's a really
great
diversity humor
right there isn't that i like to be
lectured by uh late night comedians
about how i'm racist right before i go
to bed that's my thing
yeah me too
it's it's terrific so the question is
who's walking i see when you got a
theater you know who's watching because
if they go to sleep or they leave in the
middle of the first act you better
change your mind pretty quick
but
when you own the high ground there's no
connection with the audience they say oh
you know what
if you want to see the weather channel
you're going to have to buy this whole
package and we'll sell you whatever crap
we want
so yet again
uh it's not that the inmates have taken
over the asylum but that they've been
kicked out of the direction of the
asylum because because the the the
inmates of the asylum were the artists
right when you kick the artist out say i
get it
i know how to use the theory i know how
to use film i'll tell people
what life is like
that black people are people too
everyone's people to accept the jews and
that sick people are sick and what they
they deserve are
you know there used to be all these
plays in new york but sick people people
were blind people who were deaf blah
blah blah
they always won the pulitzer prize you
know for telling us
that the bad guy doesn't the bad guy
realize that a blind person is a person
too
so you come in humming the play
but nobody likes that play except the
pulitzer prize committee
what about sort of the disney vacation
of the theater that you know in the
heyday of the theater it was all it's
everything you're talking about it was
these incredible independent writers and
playwrights who could come up with
original stories and now basically
everything is a redux of a disney movie
either from 50 years ago or sometimes
from three months ago
yeah well when i was a kid uh in new
york the theater district
was
a slum it was dangerous
it was sex trafficking and confidence
men and
mugging and massage parlors and [ __ ]
houses and pool halls where you can buy
anything in the world
and great theater
but as the
the
the theater brought people to look at
the the cause of decay is always growth
right
when the growth stops at some point is
always has to stop
decay takes takes over to as you know as
the yogis would say to repurpose it for
the next thing
okay so the the theater district at
especially from 42nd street is all when
when the middle class left new york the
theater still existed
but the middle class couldn't afford to
live there so the theater because it was
a money maker
appealed to tourists
that's who goes to the theaters all
tourists so you can't appeal to the
tourists with a new play by a new guy
nobody ever heard of on a subject that
you can't reduce to a tagline
no one's gonna do that because you don't
cost whatever costs five million bucks
to stage at play
so because
so the artists aren't coming to new york
to who wants to go do that play
you know
anybody can write that play
and i was looking at it it was a really
they used to have ads on tv or we should
watch tv years ago they said
not actors real life people right the
people in this commercial are not actors
they are real-life people
i realized if you turn it around what
you say is yeah i get it you look good
to me oh you don't need to be an actor
right
so you don't need to be an actor if
there's no scripts
because anybody can say you know i'm
kind of like i don't know i kind of like
look around and i kind of say you know
anybody can do that anybody can write
that garbage
where the artist is going to grow they
aren't going to grow in the in the
cities
they can't afford to live there
right and no one's going to put on their
stuff so something else will happen
so how do we get out of this thing i
mean it's connected to what the purpose
of the book is the point of the book of
this this pivotal moment you know can we
can we save this great experiment
but how do we get out of this sort of
culturally politically
uh
spiritually however you want to take
that
well you're doing it i'm trying to do
something
sure i mean what what what you know it's
like golda meier said remember her her
secret weapon
remember what it was
i should know this i should know this it
was the people it was
it was the people she said
no she said there's no alternative
israel is a secret weapon there's no
alternative
right so our our secret weapon is there
no alternative so is that going to mean
we're going to die at our post yeah
maybe
sure we're going to die anyway so the
question is how do we want to spend our
lives in the midst of this vast upheaval
so for years i thought it was a huge
mistake on the right for people to say
well if if we did this if the
republicans did this i can't believe
that
well it's time to believe it now
it's because it's true
that that we there's a moment in our
country that something new something new
has to emerge and we're either going to
emerge into a um all civilizations die
we're going to emerge accept the jews
which is why people hate us
we're going to emerge into a vigorous
maturity
or we're going to be taken over by
russia china and iran
there you go
i suspect you don't think that the
people in charge at the moment are quite
up to the task
well they aren't in charge they're along
for the ride you know there's a bunch of
um
politicians with a couple of exceptions
are [ __ ]
thieves
thugs and fools that's what politicians
are all of them with a couple of
exceptions that's why we have a
constitution
because the people who wrote the
constitution understood that right that
they were just regular guys and right
now regular guys and women
right and that maybe
they would abide by the rules
and because they weren't going to abide
by the rules every couple of years we
had to vote we had to kick them out
because they didn't abide by the rules
and
if they were caught cheating lying
whoring whatever
the newspapers would rat them out
right so newspapers don't do that
anymore the legacy newspapers
and if you look at the politicians who
weren't [ __ ]
thieves thugs and fools
what happened to all of them
they killed him
right put pretty good examples my
favorite jew jesus killed him
churchill they threw him out of office
right saved western civilization they
shot dr king they shot lincoln they took
trump who only wanted to do a good job
and treated him worse than any other
citizen in this country has ever been
treated and they're still at it so the
people who say wait a second no no no
do not look behind the curtain
or the left and so the right says
there's nobody there that was what my
book was like the secret knowledge isn't
any secret knowledge because what does
it cost
what
here
here's what politics is it's
the post office
the navy and the army and the marines
and the coast that's it
anything beyond that
you're going to attract the horse
thieves
on fools
so trump comes in and says yeah let's
deal with that we'll let everything else
go ahead they want to kill him
because he's completely opposed to the
zeitgeist to this through the spirit of
the time on the left
so they say oh my god he said this and
he said that about grabbing the girl
blah blah
that's [ __ ] that's the same thing as
saying that jews you know they're greasy
you know
it's it's it's finding a reason for your
prejudice that seems to make sense to
you
or say oh okay you know he's got a big
mouth and he sticks his foot in it
therefore
i tell you what let's open our borders
and and give all of our money right
about it start a nuclear war with iran
that seemed does that seem like a good
idea so the people and the conservatives
say that's a rotten idea
let's stop at using the means at our
disposal
the problem is
[Music]
in any cat fight
the person screaming the loudest is
probably on the wrong
because the other person is saying well
okay i get it you're out of your mind
let's abide by the rules and see if we
can uh come to some mutual agreement so
that's the right so that's why the white
gets accused of everything
so so how do you think we shift that
paradigm i'm sure you've heard the
phrase the breitbart phrase that
politics is downstream from culture the
the right obviously lost culture over a
certain amount of decades i think i
think that actually is shifting right
now a little bit at least but in terms
of art and everything else is there
something better that
say right leaning or conservative i mean
you described yourself before as an
old-school liberal i mean
that's what put me on the map i was
trying to save liberalism from the left
five years ago or or seven years ago uh
but for any of us that are roughly
freedom loving you just want people to
live and let live kind of people what
can we do culturally or artistically
uh or through the type of work that you
do to to turn this thing around because
it's not going to be the political
leaders that turn it around obviously
we can't do anything because that's not
the purpose of art
art
is the conjunct the conjunction of
inspiration with uh an audience that the
artist has some inspiration and if the
inspiration is reducible to be kind to
black people hate white people or or uh
people dying of cancer deserve our
compassion that's not inspiration so
that's what art is art is art is a
very close it can of course become to
religion and it's not at all connected
to politics
or culture
or it's it's like uh the oyster
like the oyster makes the pearl but the
oyster can't use the pearl
but other people can use the pearl but
the oyster cat the oyster is making that
pearl to influence people to dress up
their honey when they go out to the
nightclub
right the oyster has to make the pearl
it's going to go nuts
there's nothing that art can do what we
can do is speak the truth to each other
and be and not give in
not because it's the daily uh erosion
of life of i'm going to tell you my five
pronouns or
would you like to you wait a second you
have to identify yourself or are you
vaccinated this constant
each other day to day which is killing
and to be able to deal with this retail
is exhausting it has to be dealt with
wholesale and the way you deal the
individual deals with wholesale say
thanks i'm not playing i'm not playing
that game
you know it's like what what we learned
from you know anyway from you know gay
friends gay liberation 30 years ago 40
years ago we're here where queer get
used to it
right it's not my problem that i'm gay
right if you've got a problem with that
that's your problem
so that's what we have to do we have to
speak up and say you know and in fact
we're here we'll clear get used to it
because then it starts to crumble a
little bit
and that look on people's face you know
that you've seen it where they say oh my
god he's not
he's not playing my game
that actually uh gets nicely to a phrase
that's in the book that i really loved
you talk about a virus
of conformity and and that seems to be
it almost more than anything else that
the media the politicians the people
you know covid vaxxes
gender pronouns the whole thing that
everyone is in on a bunch of stuff
that nobody really believes
that's true
but as shakespeare another jew said
truth's a [ __ ] that must be whipped to
kennel while lady the brock can sit by
the fire and stink ladies abroad means
of the female dunk
truth's always a [ __ ] that must be
whipped to kennel
okay
here's the thing about religion think
about the torah is it says behave in
this way and you'll be
that's what god wants he wants you to do
justice love mercy and walk humbly with
god the rest of it is not in your
control
right
like they say like it was cicero
somebody has said when someone said what
do you do when the tyrant says do a b
and c or i'll kill you
he said you say to the tyrant i never
told you i was a mortal
so the question is
if you were given the chance if they
came to you and they said okay here's a
woman today
i need you to recant
right because hey if you don't recant
we're going to ruin you
and if you do recant we're going to make
you a billionaire
up to you what are you going to say
well a i would know they're most likely
going to make you a slave actually not a
billionaire if you do recant especially
if you're accounting for something you
didn't do
uh exactly so but another way to look at
it is i i never told you i was immortal
yeah right i'm are you gonna are you
gonna say that you're going to ruin me
for not proclaiming that men and women
can turn into each other well that's
your that's
that's up to you it's not up to me
what's up to me is is my conscience
right now am i going to fall off the
wagon and be a coward sometime be a fool
sometime and be wishy-washy probably so
what do you do then you get back on the
wagon and you meet the best people in
the world don't you
no you absolutely do the people that
i've met on the other side of this thing
it's it's incomparable to what i was
doing before incomparable it's like ruth
weiss at harvard teaching at harvard and
teacher comes up to her and says ruth
you know i want to say blah blah blah
but what will happen if i tell tell the
truth which said you'll be free
so
it's it's better to be free it's
exhilarating to be free and it's you
might as well blow your [ __ ] brains
out you know if
having seen a little bit of the truth of
our contemporary civilization you say
yes but
i'm going to conform because you're dead
then you're just dead
i got one more for you
what's inspiring you these days what do
you look at or see or hear or listen to
or read
that you go
that's that's got the thing that i'm
looking for
or at least got the spirit of it maybe i
read everything because that's you know
what i do all day
years ago i was going out to my office
my oldest daughter was about 10. she
said that were you going to say i'm
going to work she said nighty night
because that's what i do you know i nap
all day and i read and every once in a
while john johnson down but i discovered
some really great writers in the 20s who
are writing about business there's a guy
called jesse sprague
and he wrote several books about about
the building trades and about
the wholesalers and about credit and
their romances their fists um
roma um what do you call it fictional
romances of an imaginary guy in these
trades and he takes all of america apart
and he makes just fascinating
the view of the 20 check it out jesse
sprague
the romance of credit
or confessions of a building trades
contractor marvelous
so i ask you what's inspiring you and
you go you throw me back 100 years that
sort of says everything i suppose
well there's listen barry weiss is
inspiring me you know barry started a
university of austin texas
and you know she asked me what i would i
play along so i'm going to play along so
that's inspiring
um
young people today like you know barry
said to me dave dave she said
don't be a curmudgeon so i said oh my
god that's true i got to stop being a
curmudgeon right and saying oh you know
grandpa says when i was young far far
far well of course that's true
because the point is not when i was
young things were better of course they
were better because you were young
but now what you know so what can i
contribute i'd love to contribute you
know what can i contribute to my
magnificent country right now
tell the truth the best i can you know
that's it
you're speaking my language man david
i've really enjoyed talking to you we're
gonna link to the book down below and uh
i hope you'll come to the free state of
florida i don't know if they're gonna
let me back in la so i don't know that
we could break bread there but you're
welcome here in florida anytime thank
you so much it's a pleasure talking to
you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell